the vast majority of what you have seen
so far in geometry fits into this
category of what I've got on the board
okay but if something is true it's
converse is also true this is true it's
converse is true okay and you can
multiply our examples but it's not
always true a theorem does not always
imply its converse right and i'm going
to give you the most mmm um it's not
that common but it is the most common
example of a few where the converse is
not true you're going to need your ruler
here and you're going to actually need
to do some measurements for me okay so
here's what I want you to do I want you
to draw for me three parallel wires okay
but I want you to draw them in a
particular way on this vertical line
here I'm going to mark out and you I
mean on your page maybe you can make it
sort of like maybe draw out a section
that's four centimeters here and two
centimeters here right so with these two
intervals I now have one two three
points and that's where I want your
three parallel lines to go through okay
they can go at any angle but if you want
to be nice and simple and consistent
with the rest of us maybe you could just
make the perpendicular to this line
doesn't need to be but it would just
make your illustration simpler
so I have three parallel lines running
through this it could be foreign to
honestly it can be anything that you'd
like but this will just make the number
country of its simple for us okay so
before I add anything else to this
before I had anything else to this we
have three parallel lines you know what
those are that line you started with the
vertical one cuts all of those power
lines it goes across them so it has a
special name start to the team I don't
know I transversal right because
literally going across that's what
friends vessel means I'm your parallel
lines okay that's you this diagram of
four lines we're going to add another
transversal but this time we're going to
do it off at an angle rather than like
nice and perpendicular you can draw it
at any angle you like in fact look at
the person next to you and make sure you
draw at a slightly different angle ok so
I'm going to draw mine here okay like so
I'm going to do that and I've created a
new transversal and it's offered an
angle maybe someone will do it like that
or or off going from bottom to top left
to right but the point is sure another
transversal make sure it hits both of
them so only call this transversal one
and transmission
okay now you remember we started this
thing off by saying four centimeters 2
centimeters okay now you all have a
bunch of other second transversals I
would like you to measure out these same
portions of that line that by the way
these portions also have a name this 4
centimeter and it's 2 centimeter bit
that's been cut off because the way it
to invade is through those points of
intersection okay we're actually going
to borrow or where we've been using all
the time for when things intersect which
is that this line or actually take this
interval and this interval are called
intercepts
now is slightly confusing because you're
used to thinking of intercepts as points
but in this context it's really these
intervals that we're interested and in
their late so I have two intercepts here
I know what their legs are I to find
them you've got two new intercepts I'd
like you to measure them out you should
all get slightly different numbers get
your rule up is accurate use possibly
can so you're going to measure this
intercept and this into sense okay so
measure that
when someone is a key from the ashes
yes
good yes you get a rule I'm off a little
bit so it's actually six seven years you
gonna jump in regionals are making it
okay so that's enough time if you don't
measure yet that's okay most of you have
and you'll notice things like this on my
diagram at least and these intercepts
must be longer than the original into
that I drew by the way can anyone tell
me why they have to be longer must must
oh very good well we started off at
least if you did the same as me we
started off making these perpendicular
okay so if you imagine this kind of like
is crossing the road this line is the
shortest wait across the road because
the perpendicular distance between two
lines is the shortest distance is no
other way you can draw it short up so
therefore this has to be longer there's
all variety of numbers that I'm hurt
I've heard you know say five centimeters
and 2.5 centimeters I think someone who
did it quite close to four point two
centimeters and 2.1 centimeters I can go
auto load it on you should have some
similar kinds of numbers because we're
on the same scale what do you notice we
should see is that every time this
intercept up here no matter how long
your intercept is anyone's got different
one this intercept is always twice as
long as this intercept do you see that
like whatever you've got and the reason
why is because the original intercepts
that we drew you know also in this ratio
I care now pause for a second we have
just observed right and we have um we
tried to do it experimentally and I
literally mean that
that you repeat an observation you've
got you by the 24 x 25 x okay and we
have seen the same pattern over and over
again so now you're the position of a
well scientist whichever you are sorry
how would you phrase this property that
you seem to observe could you theorized
as in make a theorem that articulates
what property this is I want you to
write one down see if you can write one
down right obviously you know it's in
our interest and in the interest of
future mathematical students who are
going to be writing your theorem many
many times we wanted to be as concise as
possible I've already given you a whole
bunch of language to help you out write
me a sentence something that states what
is generally true off of what we've
observed here I'll give you a minute or
two to craft that sentence I love
putting you in this position because you
are so often in the opposite position
you've just been given sentences and go
ahead therefore often memorized right
can I just say I'm looking at these with
a little bit of adjustment I think all
of them and most peoples are missing a
few little nuances but they've got the
general idea like any combination of
these which is correct is acceptable you
remember what I said in our first thing
we were starting Joe entry is it clear
what you're saying right these are all
completely different in terms of like
order or the exact words that they're
using but they are all more or less
saying the same thing the parallel lines
are cut by transversals the ratio of the
intercepts will be equal thumbs up are
you have thumbs up to that right on
parallel lines any lines drawn across
the parallel lines train totaled will
have intercept in the same ratio it's
the same thing slightly different water
and on the right hand side the same set
of parallel lines I'm not sure what to
say so it's yeah okay I was questioned
the words saying I've divided
transversals in equal ratio okay I think
all those are really getting at the same
idea let me give you the textbook right
I statement like articulation of this
property
here we go um parallel lines nine words
it's not bad um let me give you a phrase
let me get your phrase which on which
doesn't sound like a phrase that an a
mathematics teacher would say sounds
like the phrase that are an English
teacher would say a lexicon is like a
bunch of meanings right to lexical
refers to the meaning of words or
symbols okay when it comes to the
lexical density how how tightly packed
meaning is in a phrase right mathematics
is right up there right we are so up
there we just stop saying words and we
just start saying symbols and expect you
to remember what the symbols mean right
here it's like a putt from one to three
every single word is like top full of
meaning okay and that's why we
introduced terminology so we I mean you
know it's it's exactly right to say
lines drawn across the parallel lines
but mathematicians are always trying to
do things faster and more efficiently
right so parallel lines preserves so
that's another shorter and more concise
and kind of more elegant way of saying
they're always going to be the same the
ratios of intercepts on transversals
okay it's not so bad considering how
much it's trying to say now he's the
question what would be the converse of
this theorem because this theorem is
true by the way you've observed it how
would you turn this around